long lines outside vaccination centers
have become
an increasingly common site in india
those who manage to make an appointment
consider themselves lucky we had to
really a struggle for it because i tried
doing it last night it did not happen
because till the time i met i managed to
log in
and book a slot everything was booked
then i managed again i tried again today
in the morning
so somehow i got the center india is the
world's largest
vaccine manufacturer but it doesn't have
enough covert vaccines
for its own people despite the
government expanding the vaccination
program to include
everyone above the age of 18 from the
start of may the number of daily
inoculations has come down from peak of
4.5 million on the 5th of april to less
than 2 million
exactly one month later now there are
signs at this center saying it's one of
the biggest in the world but this is a
private facility
meaning only those who can pay for a jab
or who have the technology to register
online
get access india has been leading the
calls for pharmaceutical companies to
drop
patents so it can boost vaccine
production
and on thursday the government welcomed
the news the u.s is supporting the
waving of intellectual property rights
but there needs to be consensus from the
other members of the world trade
organization the wto
and that might not happen soon we're
really talking about the u.s position
as it relates to the wto process
right and that process will take a
series of months
and requires a unanimous
point of view to move forward
[Music]
but time is off the essence health
experts say the removal of patents would
save millions of lives not just in india
but around the world if global leaders
really feel
in earnest that no country is safe till
every country is safe
this is the time to prove it because we
are all in it together
and there is a vulnerability of every
country
even if it has currently entered the
safe zone
if we do not control it elsewhere the
pandemic would recycle itself
india and south africa first approached
the world trade organization in
september
since then new more contagious variants
of the virus have emerged in india
with scientists warning vaccines will
have to be updated
to remain effective elizabeth paranam al
jazeera new delhi